hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close
I'm Geo I was waiting for that I'm Bart
and shout outs to Hayden and Katie under
Alani new they'll always send us a
package I love them so much delicious
and you can get it everywhere like
literally everywhere GNC so maybe we
don't know because 7-Eleven literally
needs zero help yeah they dominate the
[__] world and they're the coolest
most humble people I love them so much
but I wanted to ask you a very important
question because
we talk about serious things all the
time right yeah because we're trying to
get close like
how do you build confidence yeah yeah a
confidence and even our you know our
usual talks when it's just you and me in
bed it's like relationship and like do
we like where life is going it's always
[__] [__] that no one cares about
right yeah yeah yeah yeah so
shallow I want to talk about something
why are you rubbing the desk because I
just realized it's uneven right here I
don't know why
um so I want to talk about something
that I think all
top all couples should talk about yeah
all right we're about to go to [__]
War oh my god do you understand okay
we're gonna [__] go to war uh against
each other or with each other against
each other oh no so
you get to pick any two animals to
represent your kingdom
I get to pick any two animals to
represent my kingdom fictional are real
let's go with Rios it's grounded God
damn it and then they have to fight so
to the end and I'll do this just to make
it fair
because if you pick two animals first I
pick two animals I already know yeah
you're [__] because I could beat you
right away right because I already know
what your animals what if we go one two
three and then we say it no no so it'll
be one
two three four or the other way so one
person has to be vulnerable right with
the first one
then I get to respond but then I have to
be vulnerable with the third one and
then you have the ultimate one what do
you mean vulnerable like the [__]
animal has to have like sentimental
value no just make me cry for example
because you're so [__] stupid like a
stupid [__] uh say say any animal look
go any animal no no go right now I'm
gonna show you that I'm gonna take it
back right now
what and to say any animal right now
fine camel Z exactly did not all I have
to do exactly what the [__] how does
that make you smarter than me that
stupid [__] no I just gotta find it I
just gotta find the camel's Predator So
You're vulnerable because you showed
your cards first you understand your
stupid ass
that's what I'm saying someone goes yeah
but your shit's so boring I just we go
one two three and then we say it but you
have to say two animals you have both
animals in your brain right now no we
can do one and then talk about oh you
want both of you combined you uncreative
[__] you mean combined like
they're murdered like a liger do you
know what the [__] a liger is yeah but
you said pick two animals listen
you dumb [__] you said pick two animals
nowhere in that sentence did you say
they have to be merged
so you're talking about emerged species
else would you pick two I don't know
you're boring as [__] so I was just
going with your boring ass scenario that
sounds like this is a boring topic let
me make it fun we stayed at the same
time but now I get it it's fun because
you're merging it like a liger you
stupid [__] or a tigon fine that's
pretty good okay
okay so what do you want to do you want
to say at the same time wait so it's
real so like if I pick a swordfish then
we're [__] because we're gonna be on
land right
no they're gonna battle it out you
stupid [__] so then okay so we pick a
land then a c
you are making it way too complicated
you just pick two animals that's gonna
represent your kingdom okay and I'm
gonna pick two animals so do you want to
do it where we both say it at the same
time or do you want to go one two no
because it's different now because now
you elaborated further and you said they
have to be merged yes so how do you want
to do it
um I can go first
you go first you're gonna say both of
them well you go first so if I go first
you have to say the next two and I get
to finish mine
does that make sense yeah
so mine I'll go first okay go
um I'll do a bear
okay
I'm gonna go with
a crab
[Laughter]
it
and then I get to go and then you get to
finish it okay and I'm gonna go with
um
I'm gonna go with
and what part of the crap like like how
is it we don't know yet we'll battle it
up we don't know we don't know all right
okay
I'm trying to think of okay crab
s
okay
elephant
your turn
okay so if I said a bear
um
that might be too high up and bring it
down
um um
gorilla fire and a gorilla what the [__]
I didn't judge you crab hands you
[__] judges either you didn't have
your tone was very I'm just confirming I
was like did you want the dozen eggs
this is confirmation this is a gorilla
you went oh gorilla that's Georgie okay
so are you gonna have
uh Barilla or gorillaire
what's the difference
um top half like are you going top half
because the tiger and the lygon are
different
always
a liger and a tiger
are different they're different animals
so how is this getting merged is what
you want you want yeah so whatever's at
the front yeah is the front fine so the
front is the face of the bear the body
of a [__] gorilla it's a torso no
it's torso it's half and half
okay what do you have okay you [__]
said crap I hope you know you lost no
you no I didn't all right so feet of a
gorilla yeah uh body of a gorilla what
about hands [__] bear baby have you
seen those claws
have you seen those claws
I like how confident you are it's
something that doesn't even exist [__]
this is real we're talking real bad like
a bear baby yep so I'm
how you can incorporate this [__]
whack-ass crab you know you [__] up
I'm a crab offent
that's what I am
a Barilla you're a Barilla [__] yeah I'm
a crab offend so imagine a [__] crab
the size of an elephant that doesn't
make [__]
[__] first half
is a crab what's the first time what
calf are you cutting the [__] where
the belly button is so it's standing up
your elephant is standing up and it's
this half no my so my elephant is still
on all fours okay okay what's the first
half
so crabs already have I don't know how
many [__] eight legs I'm having the
Chompers in the front
the other two legs are on the ground and
then that's where it cuts off from the
crab and in the back is an elephant okay
okay and my crab event is [__] like 2
000 pounds so all it is is just the back
of an elephant and the size
you're so it has a tail that can whisk
away the Flies but it's a tiny tail that
tail ain't doing [__] okay so that's one
of your defenses to [__] in swat
flies flies away okay you can have it
you ready you ready to go [__] battle
yeah you're [__] done I just go
behind your ass can you convince me
convince me why yours is gonna why
because I have Gorilla strength okay
what's a Barilla gonna do the [__]
climb on your stupid ass you're so
[__] slow a crab is slow as [__] and
so is a [__] elephant okay climb on
me and now what what do you do my claws
dig into the [__] your crab [__]
oh my crab neck that's [__] hard
crusted exoskeleton I mean that is I
could punch a [__] crab and it cracks
I can break it open with my head the
elephant my [__] is thick as [__] it's
like a freeway the strength of a [__]
bear and a gorilla dude
the strength of a exoskeleton
I'm bulletproof my [__] torso went up
okay I just [__] cut your legs from
underneath you you bleed to death you
get a little bit weak I let you bleed
out a little bit how are you gonna
[__] kill me are you gonna know how
I'm gonna kill you literally what I
asked slow brain all right
when you come as soon as you come I'm
I'm already crawling sideways because
you're not used to me so you're already
like how do I read this guy you can't
get me of course I can I'm [__] doing
this thing no you're used to doing this
okay I can go on the side no you go
forwards and backwards I go sideways so
that's already going to confuse your
your brain your Barilla brain and then
as soon as you don't expect it I [__]
just chop off one of your limbs with my
Chompers and go and now you have no arms
at all
and then you don't even know where my
eyes are so my eyes are just tucked away
nice and neatly and I have these Jagged
sharp things around my [__] hairline
so I'll go up to you and I'll just go
like this and I'll [__] slice the
rest of you up
you're crazy and I'm big I'm like a 2
000 pound crab
I don't know I still think I'm gonna
just climb on top of you and you're
[__] all I need to do is an opening to
climb on your back I'm just [__]
chomping away I got bear teeth all
you're doing is [__] going sideways
going oh how do I get him I didn't think
this through with your short ass what if
this what if this what if we start and
I'm gonna start in the ocean then
I'm gonna start in the ocean bears and
gorillas can swim
in [__] Lakes you have an elephant
body bro what does that mean you're not
swimming like a [__] full-blown
full-blown crab you have you have the
weight of an elephant now I have gills
[__] up okay you can sit there a
little bit longer long time I could
breathe underwater all I need to do is
swim on your back how do you guys you
can't even get to my house my back and
let me get to my back do you know how
slow [__] elephants swim in water
super slow they're not [__] speed
swimmers dude they're not Dolphins but
I'm half crab yeah but not the important
half which part of the crab is important
the one that helps it swim I don't even
know how they swim how do crabs swim
exactly they just do it they're [__]
good I'm gonna I'm gonna see it
Dynamic shape okay and because of their
like flat body they're probably really
buoyant just like the way a canoe is
so they can swim like easily and they
got the swimmer fins you know crabs they
have swimmer fins in the back I'm trying
to find a video to see how they they
swim I know literally I live in the
ocean they paddle dude see they're not
[__] fast I don't need to be fine for
the [__] videos
have you seen a bear try to go past the
wave they're not going very far bears
are so fast in the water are you kidding
me which bear you seen a grizzly bear at
Huntington Beach oh now you need me to
specify whoa that's and yes and you're
freaking cheating that's not that fast I
don't have zero I have zero phones yeah
well I mean you have it in front of you
it's your fault you're not smart enough
to use I'm not gonna use it yeah I don't
know I think you keep talking about my
back you're not slippery my back is
you're not gonna stay there for very
long as soon as you get on my back or
slide I got hands on my feet dude yeah I
got algae on my back you're gonna
[__] slide off did you get this LG
from I'm a crab you said the bottom half
is an elephant yeah
yeah so I'm climbing on the elephant
part that's my bottom that's my
literally all I need that's all I need I
just need your tushy and then what are
you gonna do I'm gonna [__] tap dance
on that before I [__] Slaughter your
ass then I'ma stand up and you're gonna
fall right off
no I have hands for feet and Claws no
you have claws you don't have hands no I
said the bottom half is the gorilla I
have hands for feet okay so as soon as
you get in my back yeah jump in the
ocean I'm gonna go to the bottom and
you're gonna drown you have to let go
yeah but you're gonna go slowly no I'm
three thousand pounds I'm gonna go
straight to the bottom real fast I can
elephants are pretty buoyant
oh another buoyant but they move slow
because they don't have [__] webbed
feet they just have those flat pads I'm
gonna go straight to the bottom and your
ass just okay how do we settle this then
what do you mean how do we settle who's
gonna be the final call because clearly
I'm not gonna lose why not I'm not a
loser like you oh I picked the ultimate
apex predator dude the Barilla [__] yeah
they know how to swim that's almost
incest
what do you get to judge what do you
mean you picked two things that are so
similar and that's not my problem pick
two animals oh so we're still Cobra and
a python we're still changing the rules
that's that I mean it's up to me okay
yeah so then how do we settle the score
how about you do one move I do one move
well how do we start are we all land I'm
on the I'm in the ocean like this and my
eyes are peeking out of the water I'm
like this
that's not fair you don't get to pick
the advantage point fine let's pick
someplace neutral fine like the [__]
uh the desert yes let's do the desert
the sand dunes
that's the same thing or Great Wall of
China
Great Wall in China your ass is gonna be
eating real quick why because it's
[__] crab dude
what the [__] what do you mean you know
what I mean all right obviously not the
Great Wall of China there's not enough
space okay the where where has enough
space for this where I agreed the first
time sand dunes the desert okay yes so
we're in the desert there's nothing
around us just dirt dirt and rocks yes
and Joshua trees yes okay so now when my
first move is yeah I'm gonna grab a
bunch of [__] sand and throw it on
your wet ass how do you know I'm wet
you're a crab you need to be wet you're
going to suffocate pretty soon crabs
don't have to be wet yes they do they
don't they live in the ocean they do
live in the ocean I was gonna say water
right they do live in the ocean yeah
yeah so I'm throwing sand on your ass to
dry you up a little bit more that's my
first move that's the first move of
course I need to test it I need to see
what you're capable of I'm still reading
your ass so I'm like I don't know what
does the sand came
looks like you know what I did what I
just blinked and all the sand just
dusted right off of me
you sound like taika arguing and you
know what I do now what I put both of my
Chompers in the sand and I do a push-up
and you see how big I am and now you're
scared
okay
so you ducked my sand and then you dig
your [__] things in the water and
then like this I'm like this that's your
move
yeah and I puff my chest out so you're
[__] scared what chess you said the
[__] your tushy is the elephant what
my crab chest the bottom of a crab it's
[__] looks like armor it's so scary
looking it doesn't look like armor see
okay
so then my next move is I just showed
you it doesn't work what you're trying
to do with this man I'm gonna be like oh
what's over there
you're just gonna point and yell yeah
I'm gonna be like oh
which one is yellow the gorilla or the
bear the bear so the bear goes oh like
that yeah oh then my next move is I take
my Chomper and I just whack you in the
head I'm not gonna be close enough well
how far away are we I'm out of range
clearly how far 20 feet 10 feet uh
what's your span
mice man
It's gotta be forward
oh from like nose to tail no from from
face to me
oh you can't even stretch your arms out
that I can I can go like this what are
you talking about okay so what is that
what's the range how big are you I don't
know you got to figure that out this is
a boxing okay well I'm out of range
gotta figure out the range all right
well then [__] how far away I'm paying
attention why don't we go in a boxing
ring so we know what the hell is going
on it already doesn't fit us
all right so how why do you keep trying
to change the rules well what's the how
far away because you keep changing the
rules can I bop you in the head already
but I'm uh clearly I'm gonna be out of
range I'm paying ATT I'm not staring at
where I just pointed how how I'm gonna
be like oh oh [__] it didn't work so
tell me how many feet away you are uh
maybe like 50 feet
50 feet yeah and of course you're gonna
say you have a 60 foot rate [__] no
I'm not gonna say that okay then then 50
feet then my next step is I'm taking a
step so I'm now 45 feet away
uh and how does this step move is it how
many elephant legs do you have just two
I have six total appendages I have two
Chompers one regular crab leg a pair of
crab legs and the one pair of elephant
lakes and which and you say you only
move side to side
so how are you stepping forward I first
turn to the side and then I sidestep
towards you
the realization that's true
and I went to the side to you you think
I'm gonna be stupid enough to wait for
you to Pivot and then move towards me
are you dumb have you seen how fast
crabs move I do but enough for me to
know that I need to get out of the
[__] way if I see you turning your
goddamn body well that's my move my move
is I move five feet closer no you have
two moves because you're moving to the
side and then moving five feet closer
as soon as you move I see you move to
the side I'm trying to get in front of
you again all right fine then I grab the
Rock and I threw it at your head what
rock dude we specifically in the desert
you said I know but there's just sand we
said there's nothing around us I clearly
specified I said there's nothing around
us okay well how are we gonna We need a
[__] we need a Herb Dean to bring us
closer because there's literally there's
no fighting that's what I'm saying how
do we finish this
who's gonna call it nope we gotta start
we gotta start we're like okay how about
this we start old school dual style our
tails are touching oh that's pretty good
and then as soon as the fight starts we
turn around and we're in range okay cool
okay yeah okay so our tails are touching
yeah ding ding ding we're in range what
do you do jump on your back
100 okay you jump on my back yeah now
you're dead no no I stood up I fall down
you fall down because all my allergy
okay oh [__] okay yeah
I fell well I'm Gonna Roll to the side
because I have a feeling you're gonna
try to like [__] clamp down on me
okay
which side right side or left side uh uh
probably to my left side
your left side yes so now I put my
Chomper on your neck
oh yeah I'm [__]
yeah I'm [__]
that's it I guess it's all right you
just [__] Chomp down yeah cause we're
close I went I'm trying to be fair dude
I'm trying to be fair I'm not trying to
have some unrealistic I'm glad you admit
that I have a superior animal my crab
event
oh you know what I wouldn't be falling
to the front I'm falling backwards yeah
you fell backwards yeah so then I roll
to the left I'm still behind you
yeah so I'm like this [__] I just
chomped out what the how [__] long do
you think your limbs are have you seen a
crap I have but you have an elephant
tushy remember yeah but I can still
reach behind they're [__] huge so
they go like that you ever seen the
crabs they're [__] carrying like a
big seashell on one arm yeah they're big
that doesn't mean it's necessarily long
it's so [__] bulky there's no way
you're reaching I'm like 75 crap and 25
okay fine let's do this you do that and
I hold on to your little [__] tail
that's supposed to be uh [__]
swatting flies Okay and then I put my
Chomper on your neck how you think you
can reach I could reach around my
elephant part is flexible what
it's like this it's like this how so
you're not a [__] extended bus you're
not a [__] accordion you don't have
that elephants are soft
in what way and they're in the mobility
way how are they I've never seen an
elephant be able to clean its own ass it
doesn't want to like a dog like if you
said a dog I believe you because I've
seen them been like a you I've never
seen an elephant spray water at
themselves yes because they have a trunk
the trunk moves you don't have that
anymore you have the elephant tushy yeah
and I have Chompers and I put my my
Chompers on their neck
you fell off so my Mech I have one move
right my this is my move
now what do you do well I guess I'm dead
if you have it on my neck you can still
fight not really you could put your
claws in here and then protect your neck
not really that's a [__] very strong
force I don't think I can defend it I'm
glad you admit your loss and you
literally said on my neck yeah like if
you know how to aim but I mean I'm not
gonna be a sore loser then yeah take it
and then my next move I chomped it yeah
then I'm dead what what now what do you
want and I want sure so round two pick
two number two more animals
foreign
okay my first one is
well you want to do natural disasters
I swear I feel like taika would love
this [__]
this is all tyco's [__] game like
taika right now one of his games he
likes to play is uh how we die yeah and
he wasn't all happy too what did he say
today he was like all right all right
well I'm carrying a backpack full of
poisonous because he doesn't think it's
called Poison pull it poisonous and then
you try to pick me up and throw me and
then the poison gets gets broken in the
backpack and then you die well he says
he had a he was carrying luggage and the
luggage had a bunch of broken glass in
it and there's also poison in the
luggage and he smacked you with the
luggage so now you're dead that's nice
pretty good huh yeah
yeah we play these games all the time
with this guy he would [__] love it
so we're gonna pick another two animals
you want me to go first no no
um I could make it hard
here I'll give I'll give it uh I'll give
it a thing I know but we got to figure
out the parameters because your [__] is
just not realistic what do you mean
what are the parameters what is the
stage what is what is the the arena look
like what's the ring look like it's the
UFC Octagon okay okay I don't know how
wide it is maybe 20 feet okay all right
let's do that okay and then the animal
has to start with the letter c
okay how about that
I'll go with the
why do you pick the letter you probably
already have that no I don't I literally
picked anything all right you go you
pick a letter no I believe you no you
pick a letter I believe you okay fine
I'll do uh
I'll do cheetah body
so upper half is cheetah yeah
cheetah body okay
so now my turn
I choose uh
[__] is a good one uh I choose
crocodile
what the [__] that's what I was gonna
say
a cheat on a crocodile yeah
fine you can have it I picked it yeah
clearly so now I pick another one that's
to do according to your rules a little
rule breaker okay I got crocodile and a
you found one yep
crocodile and a
chimpanzee oh that's good what half is
what
uh I'm uh
are we true to size
like what size do we pick our shopping
we're close yeah yeah like what do we
pick like do we get to pick the size or
is it like the crab now becomes the
elephant it could be any attribute it
could be any attribute
so it could be a totally outside
alligator
um but inside identifies as a chimpanzee
that doesn't make sense why what do you
mean inside what is inside outside like
his heart that's not what we're talking
about we're just talking physical okay I
don't want to know about their mental
state oh that's [__] up why not
because we're trying to battle it out
it's all about physical bro okay fine
physical I'm not trying to get to know
them I'm trying to win okay fine so so
the physical you said yes and then what
is yours what are your what are your
attributes what's the combination
I said mine is the cheetah body yeah
okay so mine is
um only the head is an alligator and the
whole body is a chimpanzee that's
interesting how you just stole my idea
but that's okay how do I say your idea
because I literally said the head was
going to be a crocodile clearly because
I said the body's a [__] cheetah but
take it if you want to cheat I said
crocodile yeah sure okay so mine would
be a crane
yeah bro a [__] bird I'll fly over
your goddamn stupid fat head
a [__] crane yeah
the Wings part of it okay and the head
that half is that the [__] hind legs
and the rest of the body is a goddamn
cheetah
wait what the [__] oh you get to judge
me wait so your body is 70 pounds yeah
or 200 pounds whatever the [__] a
cheetah whatever the [__] and your your
bird arms yeah and a beak a beak yeah of
course you can't even fly off the ground
how do you know a Crane's weak as [__]
I mean not this combination
all right let's do it ready yeah are we
gonna no [__] no
I'm trying to kill you I'm not trying to
touch you I don't want to be your homie
we're not gonna dabs it after one of us
is dead okay what's your fighting stance
start oh all of a sudden huh yeah go
ahead we're fighting [__] this like
the [__] Mr Miyagi
okay what's yours what's your fighting
stance I forgot what my animal is
I'm not gonna help you oh it's a
chimpanzee crocodile chimpanda no it's a
crocodile it's a crock of pansy because
it's chimpanzee at the bottom
okay I'm a cracker pansy so what am I
gonna do I'm already gonna start
charging close to you you've seen Planet
of the Apes yeah yeah so I'm charging
close to you now yeah I just fly over
your head with their heavy ass body yeah
I used to have claws in the back of my
paws
claws in the back of your paws well my
Paws my hind legs
your handles have claws I like how you
think of [__] chimpanzee is gonna
hold a Croc head by the way but sure can
imagine as strong as [__] yeah but the
[__] you're trying to make it too
real
cheetah it's like yeah but it's it's
already off balance
then why did you choose something more
balanced then no yours is off balance
too no mine's not off balance
crocodile's a nice head
but it's okay so if we're talking that
way then he's [__] pointing up the
whole way yeah the chimpanzee stand up
so this floor has like limited [__]
sight you can go like this oh yeah I
can't eat it so what neck does he have
the chimpanzee neck whichever neck is
good
you see what I'm saying you can't get
technical okay you ready yeah so you're
flying over I'm gonna jump 20 feet in
the air and with my mouth open
that's pretty good now what are you
gonna do [__] kick you with my
[__] cheetah leg okay so I fall down
oh yeah oh yeah and I hurt my back yeah
good so now I'm gonna go into the corner
like this and now what are you gonna do
you're gonna go in the corner yeah I'm
resetting I'm like oh [__] what was that
that was crazy now what are you gonna do
I'm gonna just lunge forward and just
give you a couple pecs to see how fast
that's too many moves you're gonna lunge
forward once well it's it's one move
lunge forward to Peck and then I put my
whole mouth around your head
I mean I get to duck
I see you go that's too many moves you
could do one move I do one move yes so
you open your mouth to bite my head
right that's your move so my move is
this that's one move yeah but you don't
know that I can't move out of the out of
the way okay fine I Chomp down and you
move out of the way okay
and then like grab your [__]
gooseneck with my [__] chimpanzee
hands yeah perfect and then I had these
hind legs imma [__] kick you off but
I'm gonna dig my [__] claws in you
yeah and then go okay and pin your ass
you're pinned
so you got my [__] you got my neck
but you're pinned against a cage or on
the floor on the pit on the [__] cage
okay against the cape I'm gonna
squeezing your neck so now I got my
other hand and I'm squeezing your other
neck and I'm choking the and then you're
starting to see the black
I think this through all right all right
um I'm gonna [__] why do I have wings
now that's kind of useless so I have you
pinned but I'm I I'm still I still have
enough [__] I'm still conscious so is
your does your neck move yep okay it
moves yep okay I'm pecking you my
leather skin your eyes they're on this
side they're in perfect range you know
what I do I go like this now you can't
do anything oh come on what are you
talking about you don't just get to
close your eyes and their armor have you
seen alligator eyelids they're not
impenetrable
they're pretty close who said did you
look this up they're like 90 fat free
look at that you mean 90. where are you
getting these [__] numbers from just
try okay you look things up I'll look
things up let me see let me see you
ready what am I looking up no no no I
you looked it up already now it's my
turn okay watch I'm gonna literally look
up
um how tough
are crocodile Islands yes please tell me
don't make some [__] up because I want
to read it too is this the the
tiebreaker
is what the tiebreaker whether or not
you can poke me in the eye or not maybe
depends on what the next move is
crocodile eyes are protected with a
third eyelid a membrane that slides
across when the reptile submerges yeah
but that's the wet thing that we see
that's not what you're talking about
okay
um
so that there's a transparent film that
allows crocodiles to see underwater
without getting any unwanted matter
thank you for wasting my time we're in a
[__] ring UFC ring okay how about
octagon okay crocodile crocodile eyelids
I'm gonna even type impenetrable
it's gonna say no Geo wins
you're blind [__]
dude look at that I literally closed my
eyes you can't do nothing about it
all of these are open I don't know what
you're saying all of these eyes are open
but you can see based off no I cannot
see that they closed it it's like
leather no we need to look at it closed
you're not even look I think you're just
trying okay type closed crocodile eyes
type in close crocodiles see what comes
up I am and then type in XXX right after
why I don't know foreign
they just look like yours when you close
them yeah but are they impenetrable
though
no look
they're slits I'm getting in that
[__] they're fine you're blind
okay you poke one one eye okay the left
eye
and you have to let go you're not stupid
enough to not let go to protect your eye
I'm Gonna Keep squeezing then no you're
not you're gonna say owie owie owie and
you're gonna have to let go okay
and I throw you like that yeah nice okay
okay so now I go like this I can see you
better and I'm charging close to you now
now what do you do I'm gonna fly on your
head and then go on The Blind Side and
like that's so many moves okay I'm gonna
fly over I'm flying in the air
okay I'm looking at you but I'm on that
side on your Blind Side I'm looking at
your flight you can't look at me you're
blind bro
with the other eye yeah I mean sure go
ahead okay I look it's hard I look at
you fly like that yeah your whole body
has to move just to let you know okay
now what do you do I see you land right
there what do you do now
well you only let me do one thing at a
time that's the rules all right so I
land and now you're good eyes looking at
me yeah like this I'm looking at you
with my good eye looking at you
so now I'm going to look at it with my
right eye
I'm gonna inch a little bit closer see
how close I can get
okay
yeah so I'll probably move like a foot
forward and kind of like just feel
second guess yeah just fill it out yeah
I grab it by the neck again but I'm not
within range I said a foot dude
you're so [__] no you're not no I'm
not you're so [__] you're gonna die
okay I just [__] my hand I threw it
at you that's pretty good
[Laughter]
that's pretty good I shielded with my
[__] with my wings
okay I do it again do not your other
Wing now I got [__] on both [__]
Wings come on I have oils on my wings
bro it just slides right off who do you
think I am a [__] sponge Wing no okay
all right slid right off and then now I
come a little bit closer yeah so I can
do one thing at a time that's literally
what I'm doing one thing at a time you
too fine
um I'm gonna try to see how far I can
extend my My Little Neck yeah to try to
[__] poke at your face on The Blind
Side are we in are we in range now or no
not yet I'm testing it I don't know yet
do I touch your skin do I go up and do I
nip it hopefully okay then I nip it and
I move right back
oh
and when you did that I used my [__]
chimpanzees and I just jumped my mouth
open
and I put your head in my mouth okay
that's two moves you see what I'm saying
you're jumping that's what you're doing
I jumped yeah I jolt with my mouth open
okay and I jump with my [__] beak
ready to strike so we're both in the air
okay
okay now what do you do now I close my
mouth and I put over your head
I duck
you miss so you get the you get between
my claw I mean my wing yeah and my face
well this time I grab your beak now and
I I get your neck how with my pink I
grabbed her beak
because earlier I made the mistake I
grabbed her neck I didn't realize you're
gonna poke my eye out okay so we're
still in the air we're still in the air
but I grabbed her beak okay so then I I
get my Paws again I stick up my claws
yeah
I mean I guess I can only do one move
right yeah so it's like
and just [__] get you and we start
falling down what do you get me on your
chest or like around your neck right
here your shoulders so I guess that's
how I can control inside my inside my
shoulders yeah yeah yeah and we're
falling down am I bleeding oh yeah oh
yeah
you can't even see what's going on on
your left that close your eye yep
what broke your beak off are we
so you don't have a beak anymore I don't
have a beak anymore I'm gushing blood
coming out like that yeah yeah yeah
so we land I think the way we're falling
because you broke it
so if you're so far okay we gotta we
gotta get a little bit of physics here
okay yeah so we're both up I do this so
most of my weight is this way but as you
go to get my beak yeah we both fall on
the side so no one's on an advent that
no one has an advantage point there
we're both on our side okay so you can't
even see bro I can see on this side yeah
but your [__] your eyes are on the
side of your head so you're just staring
at the mat my eyes I turn around I take
the back I take the back so we land and
they take my back yep I take the back
with their wings [__] yeah because this
part doesn't have wings
just like this I take [__] and I put in
your face
that's okay I'm rubbing it in their
[__] because it's gross it's okay
it's gross okay now what do you do um I
start choking your ass out with their
[__] feather arms yep
so now I have I take both my chimpanzee
hands I break your feather Wing [__]
that I didn't I didn't think of that
because you know birds have [__] weak
bones yeah they do
I think I lost why I just broke One Wing
you still have another wing
but I'm on the back you break it oh wow
I still have it
yeah I don't have anything else I just
[__] just start scratching you with
my [__] claws oh yeah I think you
lost
I have nothing else not all I gotta do
is grab both of your cheetah Lakes
and break them off yeah
and then Chomp on you I think I play
this game too fair I'm just letting you
win but you can have it how did you let
me win because I'm really trying to not
think of myself you know what I mean no
but I think the I think where you lost
is you put a non-predator in the front
half
you said c and you took mine okay I I
was trying to I think because what else
could have I picked put like an
herbivore in the front I know but you
picked a [__] Chi a [__] uh
crocodile that's what I wanted and then
you picked a chimpanzee bro what else is
left Condors it's still a [__] bird
it's the same thing you could have
picked the centipede
what the [__] is a centipede gonna do
that's even worse you could be a cheetah
in the front and a condor in the back
maybe yeah well I had it in my if if I
start I remember I picked first yeah
yeah so I wanted to take the back first
or the front you know the choose one I
know but I had it in my head I was gonna
have a crocodile for a [__] head I
didn't think you were gonna take it from
me
well then you gotta pivot you got to
think of other things I tried to and
that was the best I could come up with
the cheetah and a cougar oh we can reuse
animals I didn't know that I could have
been a crocodile too then no two
crocodiles not reuse animals what he's
talking about yeah then they can't get a
chimpanzee you just said a chimpanzee I
said a cougar I said you could be a
cheetah and a cougar oh you did say that
yeah
I panicked okay what do you want for me
you won or a cicada
cicadas are horrible what they don't do
[__]
they're not Predators by any [__]
aspect like in anything they suck they
[__] eat plant juice
so out of this game what did you learn
about me
now you're pretty creative really but
yeah you were gonna win regardless
you're the creative person in the
relationship I'm the manager person I
can keep things in order and make it
happen you're the one that has the idea
to spark my role you really think out of
both of us I'm the most creative one
um yeah I do because you have the
coolest hairstyles the coolest clothes
the coolest appearance I'm creative too
but just not in the way that you are
how am I creative and how's that
different from yours yeah you [__]
because you are a writer because you
interior design like a [__] yeah
but you're a writer you're you're a
scene creator that's been your
profession for almost 20 years yeah yeah
but look at the way you design like our
house is so beautiful of course so you
would come up with the animal and then I
would come up with everything else I'm
saying like I would probably help design
it I didn't do anything in the interior
design of this house I'm not saying I'm
not creative you don't need to convince
me I am creative I'm just saying in this
space yeah you're the more creative one
I'm not a sore loser I'm not sad I gave
it all I got I know you did I think you
did a really good job I gave it all I
got it just wasn't good
I thought you did a pretty good job you
should play this game with taika with
taika you need to bring him on the next
episode and you guys just talk about the
you could talk about the three of the
games that you play play the first one
where it's the the deaths then the
natural disasters then you could do a
little math game because I'm sure he's
going to want to do that and then you
can do that the animal ones you know
what's funny I like that he fact checks
too why what do you mean like we'll play
the game of like which animal like we'll
like we'll try to kill each other and
one-up each other you know and I'm gonna
be an eagle and I'm gonna come and pull
out your eyes mama can you do that can
the Eagles do that and then I like when
he's ready and like you know he's he's
buying time so he'll be like oh yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah oh okay and then it comes to him
and then he'll say it yeah
I don't know I don't know if I like this
I don't know I think this is outside of
my realm and I don't like to lose I'm
too competitive either we don't ever do
this again or you have to give me a
heads up and I have to strategize or we
could do something you're good at and we
could do a sandwich making contest
am I good at making sandwiches I
appreciate that pretty good oh thank you
thank you very much with the Hawaiian
roll and the ham and stuff okay well for
now I need a little break okay and we're
right at the perfect time to stop
okay so thank you that was fun I don't
want to do it again because my head
hurts okay bye but you win fair and
square both of them I really tried my
best I tried envisioning it I tried like
fact checking I tried to [__] I
didn't try to weasel my way out of it me
neither I didn't I believe it yeah I'm
not calling you I mean even though you
were kind of changing the rules here and
there let's just try to make it more
fair once you move out of time I'll give
it to you I don't think you cheated
either I think you played fair and
square and you won both rounds thank you
very much okay on that note is there
anything else you want to talk about no
okay what about Barbara Brigade what do
we got to talk about that well I want to
say that this episode's brought to you
by Barbara Brigade because all of the uh
the animals were on the ball over here
pre-workout so if you want a pre-workout
go to borrower again if you want
creatine and glycerol blend which helps
you feel your muscles and also hydrate
your muscles go to Barbara gain and also
uh we have our immunity support with
which is our electrolytes helps hydrate
you dose of vitamin C and it tastes so
good it tastes really good and then we
also have B complex which helps keep
your immunity in tip top shape and then
also our performance greens which has
six superfoods so has all the
micronutrients I kind of call like your
your insurance policy because it's
really hard to get all your veggies in
every single meal so this in one scoop
you get a ton of good stuff go to
barbergate.com check out our supplement
line and see you guys next time bye